i was like oh my god the baby's coming
now so i told casey i'm like call the
doctor that the baby's coming like from
that moment i was like
i shouldn't have called the doctor i
should have just had this kid on this
bed by myself and at one point casey
told me that a nurse got in his face and
said
the exact words you said you need to get
in her face and tell her to hold her
breath
like why are you so aggressive jesus so
future baby daddy if that happens hit
him i'll fail just fighting fight him so
then they kept yelling and then casey
ignored her and then of course because
that's because because your husband
knows he's like i went through the
training too yeah we don't do this if i
yelled her i'm going to be in the next
room
i'm not stupid
[Music]
hi
we're back how are you
welcome to another episode of big mood
podcast yeah as you can see there's only
three of us or maybe four if you include
my cat
um he's gonna make his presence known
for sure come here so he has to be
involved all the time um for those of
you who are oh that's not a scratch
for those of you listening and not
watching it is i gina gina darling who
else do we have here
nikki blades
our beautiful guest nikki blades is here
and we also have a
non-pregnant non-pregnant tiff yeah
look at me not pregnant
crazy i know
like oh god oh wait hold on before i get
into it today's episode is all about
life updates and i mean as you can see
there's a big there's a
a big update there's a thing running
around the world now that didn't exist
before this yeah we're being carried
around right now being carried around
and casey's not here because he's taking
care of baby luca and behind the scenes
we got pat running everything for us
yeah thanks hey
um so ladies how's it been it's been a
few months yeah yeah it's been a minute
i feel like i haven't seen you in extra
long before yeah you had a baby last
time baby in you now there's a baby out
of you
yeah no it's been a while
actually i don't even know when it was
it must have been at uh nikki's house
yeah it was at nikki's house yeah my
whole day was a long time ago
lived there for months yeah she's been
in vegas
yeah all right let's start off with our
guest first what's going on girl what
are you doing what's new you still look
good you smell great i love you thank
you i'll take my credit cards ruin my
credit card i know to set in between us
today she was like i need you guys to
focus
okay we can't keep having you all
smelling each other the whole episode
like it doesn't make for good it's not
good to listen to great to watch but it
doesn't it's not helpful that i'm
smelling you too yeah oh god i know i'm
distracting turn you on mickey mouse
mickey walked into my house and
immediately i suddenly just thought my
backs are arching like what's going on
yeah
gina opens the door it was just like oh
hi
oh yeah
you're back i was like hi love i know
you miss me think of me
side note lost cherry tom ford is what
i'm wearing oh that's it yeah and it's
mixed with a good girl by carolina
herrera oh you mixed your own experience
yeah
look at you
you gotta make your own original sense i
want you guys to remember me
but
work work work work work work still at
the radio station 997 now in san
francisco big bay mornings with the guys
monday through friday from 6 a.m to 10
a.m
doing that uh we're actually in studio
now oh right so i think the last time
that i was here we were still working
remotely or maybe coming in every once
in a while so now in the studio which is
a completely different experience mind
you i like started a morning show with a
brand new crew of people during the
pandemic had only met them
once before
started working and so now we're all in
the studio together and that's been it's
been interesting it's crazy how
different life is from just doing the
zoom to now being in person so that's
been really good my son my dog son is
doing well i was like wait wait wait
wait hold on
my dog son onyx but besides that it's
just been you know got the sneaker
company superb sportswear my original
shoe design is going to be coming out
later this year
so i've started designing more i've been
um co-owner in the company now for for
almost a year and i started designing so
i have some new designs coming out this
year it's i
finally am tapping into the creative
side that i kind of suppressed for a
while so
um i'll be po i post them on my
instagram from time to time but i'm like
really nervous for them to start coming
out so i have some
designs do you have to sneak pictures
already like sneak peeks
i'm going for like a lot of
fun colors right now seeing what the
year is gonna bring i've just like been
studying the fashion and where the
trends are and then wanting to drop some
that i've some designs that make it feel
more
me
and put that out there and then you know
still still with tim and rick yeah three
years now with three years oh wow yeah
we've been doing no chaser for three
years
it really does oh tim texted me last
night saying hey i forgot my watch at
the studios yeah blade's gonna bring it
over i'm like cool i'm gonna sell it
it's burberry oh yeah yeah you can get
something for it i told him i almost
till he goes um it's fake i'm like i'm
gonna tell everyone you were fake [ __ ]
now yeah
no i didn't even matter he's like that's
fine not exactly okay exactly
but yes it's still like three years oh
rick and i hung out for the first time
just him and i oh what yeah the first
time for the first time we've never hung
out just one-on-one what did you guys do
uh to went to the clippers game oh nice
yeah he's a lakers fan but
um we went to the clippers game and it
was actually really cool and tim was
like oh so you guys just talk [ __ ] about
me the whole time
no you're not that important we talked
about everything else
but that's pretty much it birthday just
passed oh hello yes thank you march 10th
oh happy belated birthday thank you
titty for you or something don't worry
you'll give me my present later
yes i just wanted to watch
it
i love when you guys celebrate such a
different type of celebration
why is everyone naked it's vietnamese
culture you know that's what we do right
there's food there's food and nudity
perfect combination that is all i want
for my birthday it's like a big booty
hoe that is
everything i want but that's that's
pretty much you know that's pretty much
it not a lot of stuff behind the scenes
trying to constantly
work on you know we never stop mm-hmm
but yeah yay
congratulations on the sneakers yeah i
can't wait to see what they look like
yeah
i want to say for a while i've been
feeling like something's been missing
creatively
you know we have work and you start
falling into a routine and that's always
exciting initially and then once you're
in your zone you're like okay
what else do i need i'm like i don't
feel like painting i don't feel like
drawing necessarily but as the guys with
the company with superb they're like yo
go in just just go in whatever you're
feeling this is your company own it so i
started designing and i was like oh wow
i forgot that i really love doing that
and i'm excited to see it like in my
hand so that's gonna um we're getting
samples together i'm also gonna be
designing a sportswear line with them
so fitness getting back into my fitness
oh you know
awesome once your sneakers come out it
gets big let me get it from you first
because i know you personally then i can
resell it in the market yeah
it's gonna be great uh-huh
you got to charge more for that yeah
right
maybe a bidding war
you know what i'ma just you know what
i'm gonna do i'm gonna say this now and
it's gonna come out eventually because i
think this might be it
you know how the souls of the sneakers
on the inside i'ma just put a [ __ ]
bikini picture of me in there oh sneak
sneak like a like a hot photo of myself
in the souls of the sneaker and then
that's the exclusive but like that's
genius design like a whole blade shoe
and then have me on the inside that's
tight oh one out of every thousand is a
full naked one oh my god that's
something
and then you gotta like bid for them we
don't know it's like a random number
like
yeah it's like a like a surprise box
like
mystery yeah and then just like the lace
covers the nipples yeah you know what i
mean just have like a lace just on the
tongue of the shoe it's a picture of me
and then it's like naked but then the
laces are covering all the all the bits
that need to be covered and if you
unlace the shoes you might get to see a
titty look at that yeah
interactive sneakers yeah yeah that's
fun
um that's like my uh so my sister's a
big like k-pop fan like the bts thing
whatever oh yeah and in their album
because their album comes in like a box
and in every box there's a photo like
it's a different photo and like people
collect them like cars like yeah this
one whatever so yeah do you remember uh
when the spice girls they had the with
the lollipops yeah and they had the
stickers
inside the lollipops and everybody would
collect the stickers and they would have
like numbers and you try to see which
ones you would get yeah that's genius
yeah collectible item mm-hmm because
then people they'll imagine they get
like 10 of the same one they're like
[ __ ] yeah
yeah
just keep buying them because they need
to collect them all
i am going to make that happen yeah
that's i'm going to happen we're going
to take it back and we'll do the whole
lollipop thing too
we were talking about the souls i
thought you meant like the bottom part
of it so then when you prep because then
i pictured like your your lip imprint
like whenever you step on on dirt or
sand or something oh my god
yo you would like you should be paying
us for this marketing my whole
brainstorm session
that's the difference between
collaborating with a company and being
able to have like creative rights over
something because now whatever how wild
it may seem it's like no that's totally
possible it's like oh why don't we do
this and that opens up for other people
too to become way more creative i
recently saw
they tried to do
it's like the sneaker and you can fill
it up with water nothing like that
and i'm like
look is it realistic absolutely not is
there a use for it yes when you think
about it you can put the hot water so
when your feet are swollen you can you
know use the hot water and yeah a little
extra
spa but we know that's not what
anybody's using now we're gonna use that
we're gonna fill it up with hennessy
right
now two clubs take a drink out you would
drink hennessy with your hands
yeah oh no no there's a different layer
underneath between layers right so it's
almost like a bag so it's like a bag and
you feel like i don't know when i saw it
inside just like yeah like why are you
like a trench foot dude
it's like that's just soggy and [ __ ]
socks gross that would be the perfect
festival shoe make it a platform here we
go gina this is for this is your idea
ready i'm giving this one to you okay
we'll sign the paperwork afterwards okay
make it like a platform or like a go-go
boot
and so everybody when they go to all the
festivals they can be put in all the
liquids inside of it
right seal that thing up yeah
it's like those clear sheets you know
free girlfriend no no no no no no no no
no no
no no no no no you saw my way like that
i know that i know that
you gotta hide the toenail
okay you see this
internet for making me not
able to show my feet and making it weird
yeah weirdness weird now but yes so you
can fill it up
because are they going to tell you you
can't take your shoe in mm-hmm right
dump your shoes out dump your shoes out
yeah you have to drain your shoes and
they put a sign up drain your shoes
before coming in but yeah you can make
go-go ones or like for they got stripper
heroes that you can fill in with like
tips and stuff so you can do that
stripper heroes the heels
clear heels you can fill it up with
stuff
see but those aren't as comfortable we
need a platform we need something that
you can actually walk around in and get
full use out of so with those drops what
are we going to name them
[Music]
slip something about
step and sips sip and steps
sip steppers lemon pepper step aside
now we have wings in our shoes
you got seasoning on your feet fill it
in with whatever you want
that's genius so when those drop in 2023
um cop your pair now we got to work on
that now
i need money i'm trying to quit
i'm trying to do nothing okay i want to
do nothing so fun just
to brainstorm your own product though
that's really that's really fun i'm so
excited to see what you come up with it
feels like now
when you start getting into that space
like everything seems possible
before i wouldn't think that it's you
know as accessible as it is because when
you're not in that world it seems so far
away but then when you're in it you're
like oh my god i can make anything i can
do anything i can create i can find
other people that are doing the same
thing
so it's it's fun
because now that world feels unlocked
what's the sneaker company or brand
called superb sportswear superb
sportswear so is that the same um
because i remember you had your own
merch line yeah so that was different
okay that was different that was just
all me i did that myself um that was
with nikkieblades.com i designed all of
the merch
and i love clothing i love the designing
part of it and so when i when i dropped
that you know everybody got to come out
with their own line and it was really
cool because people want to wear me yeah
i was like all right
y'all want to walk around with me on
your shirt like that's dope so i
designed that like every step of the
process i'm so
like attention to detail when it comes
like the fabrics and the customer
experience for the amount of pr boxes
and the amount of companies that we've
worked with it would be so disappointing
to have someone that knows the ins and
outs of it to drop something that wasn't
like a good product so i was really
really focused on making sure that when
people got it it wasn't like oh it's
clearly janky or we felt cheap so that
was separate but it helped prep me for
working with the company because i know
what i like and i know whatever i put my
name on
i want it to
feel like i care about you and i'm not
just trying to get money because it's
really easy to just put stuff out get
that bread and move on
but you want people to have that
experience so yeah for sure yeah so it's
separate so my partners um they're super
creative they're amazing the company
like
they were really about putting a woman
in the company they were like we want
that and so i've been working i modeled
for them
years ago and that's how it started yeah
so i started off modeling with them and
we just kept that relationship and they
weren't even making shoes when i was
working with them it was all clothing
and then jokingly on one of our trips i
was like um oh yeah superb's gonna come
out with sneakers this that in the third
and then they kept that clip and when
they dropped the sneakers just like yeah
you called it about like five years ago
yeah
so they're really supportive and they're
all about like our group shop is like
hey
what do you want to do make it happen
like just don't think no more just like
start creating and you already gave us a
great idea with the sneakers yes next
yeah they're like yeah we want you so uh
before anybody else steals you and
realizes that you can do this like we
want it yeah but yeah so that's um
that's separate
it's uh
completely two different worlds but now
it's allowed me to have access to get
back into that and kind of like a bigger
um like i have a company behind me now
yeah versus just me having to do it
myself and now they're like no cool we
got samples you got to fly out they're
based out of san diego so i'm
out this way you know yeah thank you
bravo yeah we work
we're awesome i'm sorry thank you thank
you that's amazing everything i'm
stealing everything i'm reselling
everything oh yes girl yeah yeah this
whole that outfit actually i'm selling
on my uh
i don't know what i'm gonna sell it on
but i gotta find something i've never
seen nikki wear an outfit more than
once i'm like in awe like damn i've been
wearing the same sweater for the last
two months
you know you still smell sexy
well
y'all get a different side of me my
morning show crew would probably think
that um that i'm homeless and i never
wear makeup because you're not on camera
because i'm not
we are on camera-ish because we post
stuff for social but
yeah trying to learn how to dress
at 3 30 in the morning
you know like i have become very
comfortable about wearing makeup and
also you know i look at my co-host i'm
like well all you men are taken and
you're gay
so you're not interested in me you're
not interested in me and you're not
interested in me so i'm not gonna try
i'm like at least i'm clean that's all
you guys get i wear the same stuff all
the time we are in sweats we're in
hoodies workout clothes i maybe get
dressed every once while they look at me
like
what's wrong with you really they're not
like what look at this eye candy now i
am
literally like an annoying little sister
to them i love that so
i could be a girl
yeah i could be dressed to the to the
tea and they're going to be like all
right [ __ ]
no look at me
like if you showed up in sweats here
we're like what's wrong are you all
right yeah
if i wear jeans that's true like if i
wear jeans they're like
that's right i've never seen you in
jeans yeah you don't need jeans not
really jeans are uncomfortable unless
they're like a certain company that
makes stretchy jeans for girls with
booties
these look like jeggings
but they're not they're not they're
these are leggings
yeah i've been living in these for like
the last four years
those make you look like you're put
together like you put effort in your day
i don't own those mm-hmm the jeans that
i have are like actual denim jeans and
i'm like i can't sit for five hours in
these
really uncomfortable but i've actually
find that to be the opposite or i have
found that to be the opposite for many
many years but now ever since the
pandemic now i'm like sweats all the way
swag
like i'm wearing these jeans right now
and i'm surprised they even fit but
these are kind of stretchy-ish ah so
these are more comfortable but i agree
like they're not they're not anymore no
i've been living in leggings like i wear
workout clothes to work because i'm
gonna go work out after work and i'm
like what is the point yeah and i don't
go out
so whenever i get to be on camera with
you guys or with you know the podcast
i'm like sweet i got all these outfits
that i actually get to wear i'm gonna
get dressed i'm gonna you know not have
to wake up at the ass crack of dawn
actually it's not even dawn when i wake
up it's night time yeah oh damn yeah you
you wake up
when i'm still in the middle of gaining
it yeah that's insane i would i would
post when like you know the get ready
with me yeah wake up a day in my life no
i'm tired i'm not filming that it's 3 30
in the morning i got a 40 minute drive
ain't nobody happy around that time no
and if you wake up chipper at 3 30 in
the morning you're a serial killer
you didn't go to sleep oh you're racist
there's only two yeah there's no between
or you're a racist serial killer [ __ ] it
dude i i would always be asleep at three
a.m like for my whole life and now i'm
up yeah i am breastfeeding a newborn so
i miss now i know what that's like i i
miss night
time like i'm such a night owl uh
what time do you go to sleep now that
you have to wake up at three years for
real uh i go to sleep by ten
years off
i know but i know
but i know it's smooth yeah
i do i use my fingers all the time
dude i'm laughing but i would totally do
it
no i go to sleep at like 10. i
amongst the group i am clearly the one
that they think is like ah she's out she
party she go
no i'm just at the gym
and i try to see my friends when i can
so that i don't become super anti-social
and just like into that life do i get
enough sleep no scared me
i was like something feels cold
but i'd um
yeah so i go i've tried to go to sleep
at 10. that's really difficult because
the rest of the people around me are
like out or they're getting off work not
that you know or they're getting ready
to go into work all my nightlife friends
or all my entertainment friends nobody
i'll be getting text messages from
people they're like good morning and
i'll be like i know you didn't go to
sleep yet keep moving from the club
right like keep living your best life
because being responsible is horrible
every day i tell you every day i think
about
you need more mom friends
because i'm always like
all my friends are moms what and oh
they're all my friends are moms i think
i'm the only friend who doesn't have
their out and they're out because
they're old all their kids are older oh
so they're like not new moms i don't
have no new ones my friends new mom
because i was like that's all these
years yeah you might be going out too
and isaac's like chilling with his dad
or
he's fine independent yeah but yeah now
with this new one now i i've been living
the new mom life okay so we could be on
the same technique
i love it and then the weekends gene and
i can hear you
but all my friends are moms
all my friends are moms i love it
because they're responsible yeah i like
that i like having friends that have
[ __ ] to lose
you know what i'm saying like i don't
know if anybody else has experienced
this like you hit a certain point in
life where you're like look the company
you keep really does affect your life
yeah so i don't have like friends that
are my friends be out y'all hoes be out
i'm too tired for that because i have a
job now but
everybody has something that they have
to live for besides just themselves and
let's be real when you ain't got no kids
you don't really have a lot of
responsibilities you are reckless
because you're just like living your
best life or whatever that is but when
you've got friends that are responsible
and they have people that like care
about them and they have to care about
they move a little different so there's
times where it's like yo does this feel
like the smartest thing to do no cool
we're not even testing the waters on
some stuff so it's nice i have most of
them i think that applies when or in
terms of like having like being a parent
and being careful to like when you're
older because i've i've had isaac since
i was 18
and you see me skydiving as much as
possible because i [ __ ] love it or
like
riding a motorcycle and being all
dangerous and [ __ ] and people are all
judging me like you have a child you
need to be more careful and i'm like but
i'm young yeah
let me live my life
regardless of what you do you still have
to live for you and even like doing
those activities don't seem as like oh
you go skydiving as a mom like i don't
think that anyone should be judging you
for that now the person going out at the
club or missing their kids uh you know
recitals and that stuff like oh that's
more irresponsible and dangerous than i
think you wanting to live an exciting
life yeah and the thing is stop [ __ ]
judging all the moms
stop doing that because now
y'all parents were reckless as oh yeah
we if you really
think about
who raised most of us
they didn't have a microscope on them
and people judging them constantly and
being like why are you doing this why
are you doing that first off all of our
parents are partying okay they were all
out it's true yeah they were telling us
get the hell out of the house and we
didn't know what they were doing and
nobody knew what they were doing my dad
was getting arrested
my dad was partying actually my parents
were partying dude i was partying with
my parents
parties i would sneak beer like all the
time all my cousins we get [ __ ] up
yeah
hey i'm hawaiian they taught us how to
bartend early like hey you see the cup
empty you grab another one they taught
us how to make tips oh hospitality we
were like raised to know how to like
provide customer service and there's an
opportunity to make money because you
know all the family events there's
gambling everybody's like betting on
something there's some sort of game
going on and there's money everywhere so
they would be like look if you want to
figure out how to get some of this money
you better be like oh do you need
another drink
yeah they taught us real real early
but yeah so my friends they
they you know it's a nice balance and
they're really understanding because i
have a job
yeah so i don't get the guilt trip which
is nice but i can only imagine a few
years ago with like the friends that i
was around oh the relationship i was in
man that's honestly probably why my
relationship ended when i got a job
i had heard of that before yeah yeah
because i can't do the things that i was
able to do before now i'm on a
completely different schedule and i'm
like yeah that's really tough but yeah
okay enough about me
you all already know me so it's not i've
been i've been here enough times
i'm gonna take genius stuff so let's
talk to ted
using the internet without expressvpn is
like leaving your laptop exposed at the
coffee shop table while you run to the
bathroom most of the time you're
probably fine but what if one day you
come out of the bathroom your laptop is
gone every time you connect to an
unencrypted network whether it be cafes
hotels airports any hacker on the same
network and gain access to your personal
data like passwords or your financial
details
your data is valuable hackers can make
up to one thousand dollars per person
selling personal info on the dark web
expressvpns have an encrypted tunnel
which creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet so
hackers can't steal your sensitive data
it'd take a hacker with a super computer
over a billion years to get past
expressvpn's encryption it's also very
easy to use just fire up the app and
click one button to get it protected it
also works on all devices from phones to
laptops and tablets and more so you can
always stay secure wherever you go for
me i have a bunch of accounts like
social media and other companies and
even my bank accounts that i don't want
people to find out that's why i use
expressvpn so secure your online data
today by visiting expressvpn.com
big mood that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
big mood and you can get an extra three
months for free once again that's
expressvpn.com
big mood you know for most of us
learning a second language in high
school or college wasn't exactly a high
point in our academic careers i can tell
you for a fact it was not one in mind i
took french in high school and all i
remember is how to count from one to
like 20 and that's it like i cannot use
french to save my life now thanks to
babel the language learning app that
sold more than 10 million subscriptions
there is an addictively fun and easy way
to learn a new language whether you'll
be traveling abroad or connecting in a
deeper way with your family or you just
have some free time babble teaches
bite-sized language lessons that you'll
actually use in the real world so i've
been taking french and i can now say
good morning good afternoon can i have
the check please um i don't know so many
fun things because i have traveled to
france a couple times and now ever since
i've been using babel i'm like oh i feel
a lot more confident next time i get to
go visit france hopefully soon so anyway
babel's 15 minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go other language learning apps use
ai for their lesson plans but babel
lessons were created by over 100
language experts their teaching method
has been scientifically proven to be
effective with babel you can choose from
14 different languages including spanish
french italian and german plus babel's
speech recognition technology helps you
to improve your pronunciation and accent
there are so many ways to learn with
babble in addition to lessons you can
access podcasts games videos stories and
even live classes plus it comes with a
20 day money back guarantee so start
your new language learning journey today
with babel right now save up to 60 off
your subscription when you go to
babble.com big mood that's babble dot
com slash big mood for up to 60 off your
subscription
babble language for life
tiffany yeah
you know i'm part
yeah there's no bubba in here no so
tomorrow he turns two months
yeah he's gonna be two months old
tomorrow and man it was wild so the last
time i talked about
like my birth plan and stuff neither of
you guys were here
but
like the audience knows like i was
talking about wanting to have a birth
center birth and
as natural as possible
and unfortunately that didn't happen
that is so insane to me okay so what
well because i was trapping i was i was
mentally preparing and like educating
myself and like learning about the
natural physiological process of birth
and how we're meant to give birth and
like our bodies are built perfectly to
the tea like we're supposed to
give birth on our own like without
assistance and we're able to tap into a
euphoric
labor like we're able to not be
in like it is somewhat painful but like
not
not torturous though it's not supposed
to be torturous we're supposed to see
like that like that mentality is what
society feeds us mainly like the media
and because we're already coming into it
scared
like you know the fear just creates more
fear and like more pain and it's a it's
a pain cycle it's not supposed to be
like that and i i was educating myself
on the fact that it's supposed to be
euphoric and like pleasant and like just
a beautiful
kind of time kind of what they've made
us think like the hippie dippy people
were talking about because there's like
oh whenever i hear somebody talking
about birth is so beautiful they've kind
of painted it a particular like you're
crazy because yeah and it's insane
because it's the actual opposite okay
like you're that's how it's supposed to
be oh okay just like keep letting us
know it's like this it's like imagine
as a society everyone would talk about
every time you take a [ __ ] you need a
push and it's supposed to hurt
every time you take a [ __ ] it's supposed
to hurt that's [ __ ] wild right i
would not want to poop exactly and
that's exactly what society has done
around labor yeah like it's a
physiological process like when you
breathe when you swallow when you poop
it's all like your body knows what it's
doing and it doesn't on its own that's
what labor is supposed to be like anyway
that's what i was preparing for and i
was trying to give birth at a birth
center
i had the option to do it at home but
i'm like oh it's my first time i want to
do it forget about a birth center
forgive me what exactly is a birth
center so at a birth center they'll be a
midwife instead of a doctor so doctors
are trained for emergencies like they're
trained to help with like there's a
problem i'm gonna fix it but being in
labor and not having any risk like if
you you're low risk like your baby's
healthy you're healthy there is no
problem to fix it's just
you just receive the kid and that's it
okay but because
doctors are trained to fix problems
that's what ob gyns do and like they're
great surgeons they're great at helping
emergencies
but
most of uh most of
almost everyone that's going into labor
is not an emergency but they treat labor
as it's an emergency so at a birth
center it's more understood that yeah
it's like this isn't an emergency this
is a natural process we're going to
create an environment for you that feels
homey and
low lights because like that's like
animals they deliver in like low light
it's quiet that's where animals like
we're supposed to deliver in that sense
but hospitals bright lights hectic lots
of people it's [ __ ] up
and so like that's what the birth center
was supposed to be okay it's supposed to
be like a homey nice calm vibe
where i get to like channel like just go
internally and like let my body do its
thing and have a nice blissful birth
that's what it's supposed to be like
and so they have midwives and so
midwives are trained for that to just
let your body do its thing kind of thing
anyway so
my birth center that i went to what i
was supposed to go to they don't they
only take low risk right because
remember it's like low risk you're meant
for natural happy birth higher risk now
you got to go to the hospital because we
don't know what's going to happen and
you've got to be safe complications yeah
okay okay but what happens if you have a
massive complication at a birthing
center is there a doctor um so they have
procedures to transfer you to a hospital
okay like the actual hospital rate
transfer rate is like minuscule like
it's so so so rare because that's how
rare actual emergencies are in labor in
in the proper
place with all the proper yeah the steps
being exactly the proper steps because
once you go to hospital it's
intervention after intervention after
intervention but in the birthing center
can they like sow you if needed
c-section no it's not c-section no
c-section so what if you tear and we'll
do something better so you um if you
well so that's the other thing too is
like you're not
you're not supposed to tear like if
you're if you're if you're doing
everything correctly and you're
you're going into it with your with your
brain prepared and you're like
visualizing yourself open and you're
breathing through everything you're
being grateful you're being happy
your body is meant for your to push out
your child so your body will create the
space for your child to come out
if you are allowed that
that space
but
like for me for example i couldn't have
that
i'm gonna do a whole video on my own
channel where i really talk about the
entire birth story and go into details
but pretty much to sum it all up i had
to go to a hospital um and because i was
five days too short from being able to
be accepted at the birth center i was 36
weeks and two days and i had to be 37
weeks in order to be at the birth center
and that's like like low risk like full
term
because i was 36 weeks in two days when
my water broke
that means
baby's technically pre-term so preemie
now okay even though it's five days
short like that's just that's the hard
cut off so i had to go to a hospital i
go to the hospital and i'm like adamant
that i don't want a c-section i isaac
was a c-section and so generally
speaking in this world if you've had one
c-section they want you to have another
one because it's just easier like it's
just like
you already had this procedure done
let's just make sure you just have it
again and just get it get the [ __ ] out
of here and have your baby just like get
get in and get out like that's what the
hospital process is like
and so i once i got admitted they're
like well you've
never come to like i didn't go to the
hospital i didn't have a doctor there i
didn't have an ob
so i'm like a complete stranger off the
street and they're like we don't know
your history and i'm like well i'll send
you all my history and so i had my
midwives facts everything um but they
were like yeah it's really up to the
doctor if he's gonna let you
give uh it's called the tolak so trial
of labor after cesarean
or aka of v back which is vaginal birth
after cesarean so that's like they have
these terms after you've had a cesarean
like now you're a completely different
kind of patient oh because there's a one
percent
one percent chance that my incision can
open
from the c-section
but because of that one percent they're
like
it's a huge risk like
one percent they they treat it because
of the liability they treat it like as
if like that's going to happen to you so
let's just give you a c-section like
that's how they view everything because
of the liability so anyway so then um i
was really adamant i'm like if if the
doctor that comes in and like because
there was three doctors on call and the
first one that they gave me or whatever
they were like well let's see if he'll
let you do a tolac um and if not then
we're just gonna have to prep you for
surgery i'm like if he's gonna if he's
not gonna let me do a toll act i'm
checking myself out i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm going to another [ __ ] hospital
like i was like that's that already was
the the
the introduction to my experience in the
hospital already and it was just really
disappointing because i i had to fight
for what i wanted and what i wanted to
happen to my body into my baby and it
was really stressful it was literally
the exact opposite of what i wanted my
experience to be like
like for example like i didn't want to
have any cervical checks like there's
other ways to tell like how dilated you
are to see how far along you are but
they're just like no no we have to stick
our fingers up your vagina to see how
far along you are so it's like the first
time i was like okay
fine this one [ __ ] time so you know
how far along i am i was only one
centimeter dilated when they checked me
and then from then on because he was
preterm they were telling me that they
were gonna give me this drug called
pitocin to stimulate my contractions to
push like to induce to like make sure i
go into labor because of this another
thing too with the hospitals it's like
oh you're on a clock now like you need
to make sure that you get this kid out
at a certain time or a c-section like
everything oh wow every road leads to
c-section
and and then with that kind of stress
like your body shuts down i mean i'm
stressed for you right now i could only
imagine going i i did watch my friend um
give birth
but it was
a very different experience than you
know than what i'm hearing with this
she was in labor for a long time i mean
it was just completely different so i
watched that experience and it wasn't
hectic it wasn't hectic it wasn't
chaotic but i can totally feel like i
can feel your stress sitting next to you
and i can't only imagine having a plan
in my head
and being told no which nobody wants to
hear yeah and then feeling not heard
and
just everything
not going accordingly yeah i was trying
to be really flexible too because they
always say like sure you can have a
birth plan but that could all go out the
window so i'm like okay cool let me be
realistic i'm not gonna be rigid like
baby came early water broke early
um and
so i
i was trying to be as realistic as i
could possibly because babies now
pre-term
um i was like okay fine you want to give
me pitocin to speed up labor because
it's already been six hours
since my water broke or 12 hours i think
since my water broke okay fine and like
i wasn't i wasn't progressing enough
like i was having contractions but they
weren't consistent but then they do an
ultrasound and they were like oh wait
your baby's too small we think your
baby's 34 weeks now not 36 weeks and
then if it's if your baby's 34 weeks
then that means he might have issues
breathing like his lungs are
underdeveloped so we have to give you a
steroid shot so i'm like okay give me
the [ __ ] steroid shot i didn't want
any drugs but here we are that's what
you think fine doctor i'll believe you
so we got the steroid shot and then they
gave me a pill to stop the contractions
because they wanted the steroid shot is
a two dose thing and there's 12 hours in
between each dose so they were like we
got to give you time to get the second
dose to make sure babies lungs are good
so they were trying to stop my labor um
wow and so
they i took the pill and i stopped it
for like a few hours like a couple hours
but
they came back and then i asked them the
nurse at that time
i was like so what's next like what do i
do and she was like well you're you're
on bed rest like i couldn't get up even
to the bathroom i had to use a bedpan
and uh she's like you're on bed rest we
got to give time for this medicine to
work and then we'll see like where you
where you're at with your labor so i'm
like okay and i was getting a lot of
contractions but i was breathing through
them i was doing i'm like this is my
training like my training yeah
like i've been training for this so like
i'll feel the contractions come and i'm
like being grateful and like just
accepting each contraction and
um breathing through it and i was really
calm so like my whole laboring
besides the
the [ __ ] hecticness of like dealing
with hospital people because that just
disrupted the labor process
besides those little interruptions like
everything else like i was [ __ ]
nailing it like i was doing so good i
was managing each contraction it was not
painful it was just
um like there was just pressure and
i think i was like i was having a good
time with it
it got to a point where it was like 2
a.m
and they were finally leaving me alone
and the lights were all dim it was
really relaxing casey was reading me
this um so and through hypno birthing oh
we were listening to the book there's
this thing called rainbow meditation
where he like talks about each color of
the rainbow and like i have to like
meditate and like focus on what he's
saying so he was reading me the rainbow
meditation and there were certain parts
where i tell him like okay stop talking
and when like when i tell him to stop
talking that's because i started getting
like a really peaked contraction
and so
we were going through the rainbow
meditation and then at one point like
towards the end
i got this it's called the fetal
ejection reflex and that's
what you need to not tear like that's
that's what you're that's what your body
does just like when you're taking a [ __ ]
like your body naturally releases the
poop right so this
so giving birth like my body had that
uh fetal ejection reflex where i
literally felt his head like shoot down
to like oh my god
yeah like the opening of my vagina
pretty much i felt like he was about to
come out
so that at that point i'm like oh man
like i couldn't not push like that's
what that feels like
and
i was like oh my god the baby's coming
now so i told casey i'm like call the
doctor that the baby's coming and so at
this point i'm just like breathing
through it breathing through it and like
like just my body's pushing on its own
and so he calls the nurse and then the
nurse rushes in and she she [ __ ] jams
her fingers up my vagina without like
asking her nothing i was just
so i'm like okay that was [ __ ]
painful she like went in there and then
she's like oh the head's here like let
me call the doctor and then that's
like from that moment i was like
i shouldn't have called the doctor i
should have just had this kid on this
bed by myself because from the for the
next 20 minutes
that's when
and the contractions were so intense the
whole [ __ ] circus came into my room i
counted how many people at one point
there were eight people in my room why
the [ __ ] were there eight people in my
room
there's no need for that many people um
and so anyway they were they were
yelling at me don't push don't push and
i'm like i can't not push right first of
all second of all [ __ ] you i'm gonna
push yeah like it's like i can't avoid
it
and and so i'm like on my back the
doctor's like scrubbing in and he keeps
telling me like don't push oh and then
so i had these leg compressions on my
leg which is like this machine that like
like pushes my legs together oh kind of
like a blood pressure cuff so it's like
that but on my legs because they don't
want me to get blood clots thinking that
i was going to lay there for two days
for like 48 hours right
helps with circulation so they had that
on my legs and my contractions now
synced up to this leg compression so my
contraction was from my the top of my my
uterus like the top of my belly all the
way to my toes oh my god i felt my
contractions all the way down so when
the doctor came in i was like can you
please take off the leg compression he's
like oh i don't know and he's like all
scrubbing and like trying to like be all
frantic and stuff but like he just
ignored me to take off the leg
compressions and i'm like like take
these off but it got to a point where
like my brain was so mush
that i couldn't really form words like i
they're like when that lady came and
like gave me the cervical check i wanted
to tell her like don't [ __ ] touch me
but i couldn't like i couldn't even like
speak like it was just i was it was just
so intense
the contractors were so intense and
feeling his head moved down the birth
canal was like so intense i was trying
to focus on that but then there was just
so much commotion around me and then
they they turn on the lights all bright
they're like scrubbing in all these
nurses running around everywhere and
like just like yelling at each other
like to [ __ ] get this get that and
all this [ __ ] and it was just
it was chaotic and like it did not need
to be like that
but it was and so anyway they're they're
like okay now you gotta push you gotta
push push push and so
i'm fighting with the doctor to
because he kept pushing my legs out like
my knees out
and i learned that your pelvic inlet
like if you like right now put your
hands on your sits bone so like
put your hand underneath on the bone of
your butt on both your hands oh it goes
in when you like when you
oh yeah when you spread your knees apart
those two bones comes together together
so it closes your pelvic inlet when you
push your knees in it opens tell me
which one do you need to push a baby out
yeah
open or close so
this doctor kept pushing my knees out
he's like no i'm out and i was fighting
him and i was like you know you're
you're closing the pelvic inlet i
literally yelled at him that
and if i was just so exhausted of
fighting him off at another point this
nurse comes in she's like trying to jam
a mask on my face
and then this other nurse was like leave
her alone and i was like what the [ __ ]
like all these people like touching me
doing things and like putting [ __ ] on me
and like
it was oh my god i it was
not what i wanted at all and
anyway like i end up and then another
thing that i knew is to be
to forcefully push a [ __ ] out what do
you think is going to happen to your
[ __ ] yeah that's when you get hernias
you're going to get hemorrhoids you're
going to bleed
they kept telling me to purple that's
called purple pushing when you're
holding your breath and you're like
bearing down there's no need for that
[ __ ] if you just let your body do the
infant injection reflex if that happens
you don't you don't need to push you
don't need to tear you don't need to
[ __ ] hold your breath imagine pushing
a kid out there holding your breath
anyway i'm so
like ugh still about it
they kept bullying me to do that they
kept telling me like no no like you have
to hold your breath mama hold your
breath and i'm like and i'm i'm over
here like pushing but like releasing um
i'm like
like that's how i was trying to push him
out and they're like no hold your breath
hold your breath and at one point casey
told me that a nurse got in his face and
said
the exact words he said you need to get
in her face and tell her to hold her
breath
like
why why are you so aggressive like why
are you so
like there's no need for that jesus so
future baby daddy if that happens hit
him i'll fail just fighting fight him so
then they kept yelling and then casey
ignored her and then of course because
that's because because your husband
knows he's like i went through the
training too yeah we don't do this if i
yelled her i'm gonna be in the next room
exactly yeah he's like i'm not stupid
yeah so he uh so yeah so then they they
just kept trying to tell me to do that
in an event i got just
so tired of them telling me to do things
and i'm over here trying to push a baby
out yeah no epidural no pain like no
nothing
i was feeling everything that i i gave
up like i got so exhausted at from them
like
it literally felt like bullying yeah
[ __ ] do this do this do this do this
so i'm like fine i'll [ __ ] do it so
then i just pushed my knees out i
started bearing down i started purple
pushing and then the doctor's like oh
we're gonna have to cut her
and then i'll and then i told casey i
grabbed his hand i was like
i was like because i couldn't [ __ ]
speak yeah and then casey's like no
episiotomy no episiotomy and the doctor
is like arguing now with casey like well
if i don't cut her she's gonna tear and
then all this [ __ ] and i was just like
[ __ ] fine but i guess he didn't hear
me say fine so then he didn't cut me
thankfully but
i ended up [ __ ] tearing because i
felt him stick his fingers inside to get
the baby's head out there's no need for
that let his head just come out
naturally
the key to consistent good hair days
using ingredients that benefit your hair
and functional beauty makes just that it
makes hair care products that are 100
customizable made for your hair where
it's at now and where you want to go
function of beauty is the world's first
fully customizable hair care that
creates individually filled shampoos
conditioners styling and treatment
formulas based on your hair now and
where you want it to go founded by a
dream team of engineers and cosmetic
scientists
each functional beauty product is
individually designed to be as unique as
you are function of beauty offers 54
trillion possible formulations every one
of them is vegan and cruelty free and
they never use sulfates or peridines you
can also go completely silicone free
here's how it works first take the quick
hair quiz to build your hair profile and
select five hair goals like lengthen
volumize and oil control does your hair
get frizzy in the winter but oily in the
summer function formulations are meant
to be changed when your needs change
next choose your color and fragrance and
go die or fragrance free then get your
freshly filled formula delivered
straight to your door and prepare for
good hair days ahead currently i'm using
um one for my dry hair i made it purple
and it smells like roses you can even
control how much scent you want in it
and i chose the strongest one because i
love the smell of roses say goodbye to
generic hair care today go to
functionalbeauty.com big mood to take
your hair goals quiz and you'll save 25
on your first order go to
functionbeauty.com big mood to let them
know you heard about it from our show
and to get 25 off your first order
that's functionalbeauty.com big mood to
take your hair quiz and save 25 on your
first order all right guys i have a
question how many times do you get up in
the middle of the night because if you
have a little one then you know it has
been a while since you got through a
full night without interruptions i know
that's the truth for me and my husband
casey we have a three-month-old baby and
these past three months have been full
of interruptions we have not had a full
night's rest until we received coterie
diapers which oh my goodness they're a
godsend honestly i am such a huge fan of
these diapers the hype is real you guys
the hype is real coterie is the highest
performing diaper on the market for
infants and toddlers with up to two
times more liquid capacity and up to
four times faster moisture wicking
versus other brands and that has been
proven in my household i'm telling you
there have been nights that we put our
son luca to sleep and he will not wake
up like the whole night i'm like wait
this is weird it has been like a good i
don't know five hours with the same
diaper and he's perfectly comfortable
and i'm telling you these diapers are so
freaking soft so cotery diapers are made
with clothing grade material so they're
not raspy and like just scratchy and
noisy like other diapers like you could
definitely feel a difference with
coterie and it definitely gives that
cashmere like feel
so my baby definitely has been feeling
way more comfortable for longer
during the day and night i cannot stress
enough how much i love these diapers and
you know what else is really cool is
that they are dermatologist tested and
they only use the cleanest ingredients
plus coterie wipes are national eczema
association approved that's freaking
amazing and coterie has been awarded
best diaper and wipes by both the bump
and parents.com so forget about
nighttime leeks and wet sheets and try
the rolls-royce of diapers codery right
now coterie is partnering with our
podcast to offer you 20 off your first
order plus free shipping at
codery.com big mood that's coterie
spelled c-o-t-e
dot com slash big mood for 20 off and
free shipping
codery.com
big mood
so
i ended up having a second degree
vaginal terror
it wasn't that it was off to the side
anyway like i didn't need to tear
my whole pelvic floor
was shot like afterwards when i was in
the recovering room i couldn't hold my
pee like my penis is coming out and i'm
like
there was no need for that either yeah
if i didn't if i didn't have to purple
push if he didn't have to like stick his
fingers inside and that's another thing
too like you're not you don't need to
reach the baby come out the baby could
come out on right unless there's like
your baby's head or your feet coming out
like yeah exactly unless it's necessary
so unnecessary stretching with more
hands right yeah but also it can [ __ ] up
the baby's neck like these have injuries
from delivery oh i just saw one
yesterday where a baby got a huge
laceration because they cut c-section
too deep yeah yeah i mean there's a lot
that can go wrong
i was a complicated birth but with your
situation and your preparation
and it
yeah and i was so adamant too and
telling them like listen i i like i
prepared for this like please don't do
this don't do this and then i i even had
a birth plan and it was a visual birth
plan it wasn't like a [ __ ] like 10
pages of written [ __ ] it was easy like
it was just so easy
they just didn't care he didn't even
look at it yeah the doctor didn't even
look at it he just had the nurse like
okay what okay i have her deal with it
and so i'm like god damn it it was like
anything wrong that could happen not
anything because there was a lot of good
things that happened thankfully like i
didn't have to do uh a c-section i
didn't i thankfully i didn't have any
medications like or any pain meds at
least and
thankfully luca came out okay because
they had a nicu team there that's like
there was two extra people out of those
all those people there was two people
there from the nicu team just in case he
had complications which i'm very
thankful for like at least
even though i'm complaining a lot you
didn't you found the bright side yeah
yeah but it's okay to vent about this
because this whole experience is
something that a lot of women have gone
through and i
never fully heard
about an experience like this like i
know
what my mom went through and my dad
always describes like it was i had a
very complicated birth so you know when
you describe the circus coming in there
was that moment that happened within my
mom and my dad had stepped out um my
umbilical cord was like wrapped around
my neck and also i stressed out when i
was in uh in the womb and i actually
like i almost died in there because i
choked on my i pooped myself
yeah so it was so but then also
something inside you knew like god have
i come out i'm not saying bills
have to be here
so you know like i've always heard like
how traumatic my mom's experience with
me was with with the rest of them it
wasn't but um at one point my dad said
that they had my mom on all fours and
they brought in uh because it was a
different case they brought in a lot of
what are those uh the ones that are
learning oh my god the students the
students right there students in my room
too there's way too many people and my
dad was like
pretty much my dad almost killed a
doctor because he was like this is not
how it's supposed to work yeah none of
it was supposed to happen so my mom was
on all fours at one point in time and he
was like
this what the [ __ ] are you doing to my
wife well on all fours is a good
position but it was getting too but he
walks into the room and there's
students staring at you know and he's
like this is not this is not a learning
that's not what we signed up for but
i've never actually
heard my mom tell the story
um i've always heard it from my dad's
perspective and my mom has chimed in
here and there but you know she has five
kids and i was of course a special baby
she was like
of course it would be you
but to to hear like you're not i don't
feel like it's complaining i feel any
time we have a plan and we train for
something and you and you go through the
necessary steps to to do
your due diligence do the work to do the
work uh we're not really taught this
we're um still learning about
the right way to do everything
and yes of course you found the bright
side but i feel so many times that we
don't allow people to express themselves
yeah and we tell people to just be
grateful and you're completely ignoring
the trauma that you went through thank
you so much for that because that's so
that's so a fear of mine even just i was
kind of dreading talking about this on
this so it's gonna have a lot of
judgment for sure but as a woman who i
have chills right now so as a woman who
has not had a child and i've witnessed
you know my friends go through
pregnancies and i've saw one of them
have a baby it was completely different
but we don't really give the mothers the
opportunity to express their experience
because everyone's just supposed to be
grateful that you gave life
but you are still a person your
what you went through should not be
ignored or deemed complaining because
just because you gave birth and now
you're a mother again
you don't lose you as a person and so
many times we just think because now
you're a mother that
all your feelings go out the window
because your baby is healthy and that's
also a huge problem that society has
placed upon when the bar is so low or
it's like oh healthy mom healthy baby
there's more to that so we cannot have a
non-traumatic experience
during birth for sure i really
appreciate you saying all that because
with my birth center
their whole thing too was like that like
i cried the last time i talked about it
because they treated me as a whole
person they're like how are your
emotions about pregnancy or just about
your life is there any trauma that
you're getting through every time they
touch me they ask me like is it okay if
i touch your belly right and like a
[ __ ] complete opposite in the
hospital where it's like
you're just a ragdoll
piece of meat that we have to treat and
like that's what it felt like and
it just really sucks that i was trying
so hard to avoid it yeah it's a lot of
people have fears with the hospital
not even with just giving birth again
something that you planned but so many
people avoid going to the hospital even
for just a checkup because they don't
feel seen and the people that are you
know in these hospitals they're like
honestly we're we have a 500 of you
coming in i i'm trying to do you know
yeah if you don't blame the people at
all honestly it's really the practices
like the procedures like the [ __ ]
this is our policy like this is what we
got to do and it's just like because we
know that people too yeah we know that
there's
legal
we all
nurses and patients
in a room and said please tell us all
your experiences as a human and not just
as a professional there would be so much
more of an understanding but we have
such a separation as a society between
patient and doctor
to where there's so much fear
yeah and you
and what you've gone through shouldn't
be ignored
and anybody that's out there listening
whether you are a mother or wanting to
be one or a husband or a baby daddy
anybody like listening to this should
humanize us all because we don't think
about you anymore as just a person
you're a mother and that's not fair
because i patient yeah or as a patient
and we
should hear and not judge
i can feel you right now and i can feel
that i hope someone one day when it's my
turn to go through this listens to me
and understands whatever i'm going
through because
that's scary we don't have kids i i
wouldn't even know where to start yeah
yeah no it really
there's there's like so much also more
to share about
that day like another thing that just
popped in my mind it was like that last
nurse that i had for example like i had
to take that that steroid shot and she
had to put it on my butt cheek and she
was like okay this is really gonna hurt
like it's gonna hurt and i'm like i'm
good with pain
like don't worry like i've been killing
these contractions like they're i'm good
and she's like
you're good with pain all right well
we'll see and like she died and like she
just kept like
what's this game to you lady like she
wants to talk and then i'm just like
what the [ __ ] dude like where's the
empowerment here
why are you making me doubt myself that
i can't handle pain when i'm literally
in labor right now like what the [ __ ]
kind of logic is that
that's one thing another thing too that
really
um was like
why was
when i was ignoring them to when i
wasn't purple pushing
um and they were like i was just letting
i was waiting for my body to have that
reflex
the doctor kept saying like
mama you need to push now your baby's in
distress and i could hear the monitors
like he was not in distress like yeah
the [ __ ] doctor just lied to me to
try to get me to push and then he's he
started saying he's like he started
talking to the nurse he's like yeah see
she's not pushing this isn't gonna work
you know what start prepping for
c-section and i'm like and then i at
that point i wailed and i said give me a
chance let me do this i [ __ ] and then
when i said that casey said cause i had
my eyes killed the whole time i don't
know what they were doing but casey said
like everyone kind of like took a step
back a little bit because they were just
so like like this on me like [ __ ]
attacking and when i like i literally
was holding back the tears telling them
like let like give me a chance yeah like
why are you not giving me a chance like
this is [ __ ] up like it's only been i
was only in labor from that first
contraction to when he was born it was
20 minutes damn wow it was only 20
minutes well then 20 minutes they didn't
they didn't even like they had zero
patience
zero patience to let me do
what my body was meant to do
and
yeah it's just i don't know man it's
just really
like i think about i run it back in my
head
and there's so many things that i wish i
would have said like so many times that
i wish i would have been like don't
[ __ ] touch me or get the [ __ ] off me
or not call the doctor have luca in the
bed there with me and like and then be
like okay now you could call the doctor
or don't even go to the hospital but
like i have all these scenarios but then
also
like looking at the bright side part of
it like i can't i can't keep doing that
to myself because who knows what would
have happened if like if they weren't
there like right
going back to you mentioned your quarter
wrapped around your neck something that
i learned was that
all like almost all babies have their
cords wrapped around their necks and it
doesn't mean that you're you can't
breathe or you can't you're suffocating
it's there's a tiny tiny percent chance
of that actually being dangerous right
which is when it's pinched like if the
cord is pinched that's where you're
getting your the blood yeah and like
oxygenated blood and all that that's
when it's really dangerous and then if
you're the fetal distress for sure
that's super dangerous but
like for the most part though it's like
oh
the you're not the baby's not breathing
through their right their throat or
anything so it's just like
i don't know learning about all these
things that we are taught to fear which
that has no um evidence base behind it
or whatever like i don't know it's just
really interesting um learning a lot of
things but then it sucks like i just
have this huge amount of like yucky
feelings about it because i was so
educated so adamant and i fought so hard
and i still didn't get what i what i was
hoping for but what i did get is like
the
bare minimum right is like a healthy
baby right i was healthy i'm healthy
um luckily he didn't have to go to the
nicu at all
i just got a few stitches
and i was fine even afterwards they kept
they gave me that was another thing too
like he was trying to
there's this thing called chord traction
like after the baby's born and they cut
the umbilical cord they pull on the
umbilical cord to detach the placenta
you don't need to pull the umbilical
cord it detaches on its own if you're
patient enough but doctors these days
and the procedures the policies whatever
they just pull on the cord so it
detaches and then you hemorrhage because
it's not it's not yeah it's properly
coming out so that's what happened in my
case so i started hemorrhaging and
and then the doctor was just like oh
yeah uh give her pitocin and i was just
like no i don't want pitocin but at that
point i was already hemorrhaging he's
like well she's going to bleed out
because casey was like no pitocin and
then she's like she's going to bleed out
like look she's already hemorrhaging and
i'm like you [ __ ] is because you
[ __ ] pulled right on the court and
and i was adamant about that too
beforehand i was like no core traction
but he did it anyway he didn't let he
didn't let my body just detach a
placenta on its own that's one thing
another thing i could my body couldn't
even produce enough oxytocin
to stop the bleeding because they
immediately took them away like casey
didn't get to [ __ ] cut the umbilical
cord by the way wow casey when he when
luca finally came out and i heard his
cry
i was i was moving the draping because
they put all these drapes i was moving
the drapes and they're like no mama
don't touch his sterile and like [ __ ]
you i'm trying to see my baby yeah they
didn't give me
right now yeah i didn't get instant skin
to skin they [ __ ] he cut them because
i sent casey i was like oh they cut the
cord cut the cord and then i sent him
around and when he went around he's like
no dad it's sterile hairy no no you're
gonna contaminate so they didn't let
casey cut the cord
they took luca right away put him on the
warmer
and wiped him down and i didn't want him
to get wiped down either that white
stuff is called vernix and it's really
good for your baby you're supposed to
like rub it in not wipe it off and they
wiped it off completely and then not
until like they were checking or
whatever this part i'm like okay they
needed to do this because
he was pre-term and their definition so
they needed to make sure he was okay i
understand that part but it's still
upsetting that yeah i couldn't get
immediate skin to scan finally when they
bring them around like
i'm just like dude we missed those like
precious moments moments exactly like
these
moments we can't get back yeah and
yeah and then like delivering the
placenta too like that was not very nice
because like i said he pulled it and
then he was just rough as [ __ ] and
because i wasn't numbed up like i felt
everything he did and i was just like
man it was just
it was a lot yeah
and i encourage everybody that's
listening right now to to listen from
um
uh like as a person
not as whatever anybody else has told
you or your preconceived notions or what
you experience i think a lot of the
times we listen with our own experiences
uh which causes us to judge people and
i believe that there should be more
conversations around the actual
experience of birth and what you wanted
and what you went through because
so many times the bare minimum is what
you're pretty much force-fed to accept
with how you feel um i know
i
think about those things can i deal with
this and when i talk to my friends and
allow them a safe space to share their
experiences without feeling judged i
feel like it's so vital
because
if we're just going based off of what
we've seen
i don't want to have a baby yeah yeah
that's pretty much how it's scary it's
it's terrifying to think that i no
longer become a person
um my feelings no longer yeah become
valid because you should just be
grateful
to have a healthy baby yeah but we don't
talk about the aftermath
mentally or just mentally you're that's
a true
it's a traumatic
experience
and not just for you but for your birth
partner too right i asked casey i'm like
how are your
thoughts and emotions after everything
he was just like trying to process
everything he's like yeah like it it was
a lot yeah and we don't
think about that we don't have those
conversations and allow parents
to
openly just talk about what they went
through without feeling like everyone's
gonna think so
low of you to just share your experience
and knowing you you already know how
this is gonna go and how some people are
just gonna think and not just that but
like i think by sharing and like even
though like you know i said like i was
kind of dreading talking about right but
the reason why i am talking about it
though is because
i feel like by talking about your
experiences i hope that someone out
there that's preparing to have a baby or
that will have a baby in the future can
educate themselves enough and to be an
advocate for themselves more than i
could have like even even as much as i i
was adamant about doing whatever i was
trying to do and
trying to
do um
trying to be there for for me and for my
baby like it still didn't pan out the
way
i was hoping to but hopefully by hearing
my story like it helps other other moms
out there because it's
all this is like so avoidable it's like
infuriating how
all of this is so avoidable like there's
stories of like moms having to get a
c-section because they had failure to
progress in their labor and that's just
because the hospitals weren't patient
enough or they're instilling like doubt
like that nurse like oh really you can
handle pain like we'll see like there's
no reason for that and it it's just
there's so many blocks that happen like
so many roadblocks that happen for
for a natural labor to even be euphoric
and nice and like how
it's supposed to be
because as a society we're just so
trained to be like oh yeah see birth is
scary and then what you see on in the
movies and stuff it's like moms are
screaming i was screaming too because i
i was screaming as loud as i possibly
could as i was getting him out like
those last few minutes of like pushing i
was screaming at the top of my lungs and
they were yelling at me mama don't
scream don't scream
me why what the [ __ ] do you want me to
do you're yelling at me you have all
these bright lights it's all this
[ __ ] commotion you're pushing my
knees out like it's like all this [ __ ]
where at that point at those final
moments when it should have been
euphoric and like me bringing my child
into this world and being happy
instead it was filled with anger and
stress frustration pain i i was in pain
now there was no need to be in pain yeah
but at this point with all that
commotion that happened like that's what
ended up happening and it's just
it's really disappointing
and i try like
the like for the few weeks after
postpartum
um i
i kept like trying to suppress all these
emotions like oh just be happy like okay
fine i didn't get a c-section cool
forcing yourself to be grateful i got
yeah i was like i got my natural birth
all right cool cool cool and then like i
just i felt those feelings negative
feelings get bigger and like that
resentment grow stronger and so at one
point i remember i was in the shower
and i was just like you know what i'm
gonna be mad yeah i'm gonna be [ __ ]
pissed i'm pissed just didn't pan out
this way
like i'm gonna cry i'm gonna be sad
and then like once i allowed myself to
feel those feelings like they lessened a
little bit and so i'm like you should
release it out yeah i guess that's how
you really i just i never knew this is
like the first experience of my life
where i actually allowed myself to feel
these feelings absolutely and it helped
but i still obviously have a lot yeah it
just that what you just said you allowed
yourself to feel we preach
therapy therapy therapy there everybody
needs therapy which we all do but you
know why
because we suppress
everything
you
are being told you're not allowed to
feel so you are now going to have to
vent to somebody in a safe space so that
you can allow your emotions to be
to be out there without being judged
we're so
is caught up in telling everybody how
they're supposed to feel but then turn
around and preach mental health and
preach therapy but essentially what is
therapy it's teaching you how to express
uh what you've gone through what you've
suppressed so just being able to find
safe spaces to release something that is
what you're feeling
you shouldn't have to
worry as much about
i need to just be grateful gratitude
comes from from a place of true it's a
true emotion that we feel and we're
we're constantly forcing people to be
grateful when they're not and that's
essentially guilt tripping everyone into
making them feel like there's something
wrong with them and there's more
suppressing which is more suppressing
which adds on to all these emotions that
you're already feeling that your body is
naturally going through like what you're
feeling is going to happen whether you
want it to or not because your hormones
are still
doing their own thing your body is
literally not your own at the moment and
it should be okay to have people have
these discussions and these
conversations and to listen because
if you don't talk about this
it can come out later
we we see the effects of suppressing
trauma and how they show up in our
day-to-day lives years later that's the
reason why my midwives were really
adamant about like what trauma are you
working on or like what trauma do do you
have in your past because whatever you
have
it will come up when you're in labor
exactly like you want to handle that
before you're in labor and i'm happy
that you allowed yourself
and allowed yourself to just feel
it's okay
to to not always be happy it's okay to
not always feel grateful
but that's why you have to talk through
it and you have to release it because it
is physical we talk about stress
stress kills you yeah period i don't
understand why people are still not
understanding they're like oh just relax
you try to do everything to relax yeah
now you're stressed i know your body's
going to feel it and it's one of the
most difficult things to try to get over
because there isn't just a magic pill
that makes you not feel stressed anymore
because the stress is still there yeah
you just suppress it if it if it is like
that's how people end up going to
substances right and
i'm
you know the process is still you're
still releasing and i think you sharing
should allow other people to
understand that what they're feeling is
okay you're not just being ungrateful
and complaining you're releasing the
stress yeah and it's going to help you
be a better person
a happier person a better wife a better
friend a better mother because you're
not going to be feeling this weight on
you yeah and you're around people that
want you to just keep letting it up yeah
because one day you're not gonna feel
that weight anymore yeah because you're
not carrying it around yeah it may not
be tomorrow but
i hope other people hear the release
because i can feel you're like lighter
already yeah
yeah just like sharing that
and thank you thank you
it's a lot you know to to learn yeah and
to
feel like you can feel it but yeah i
hope that it just continues to
keep getting out there yeah yeah get it
all out i'm sorry you went through that
but i'm glad that you can actually let
it out
yeah
thank you i appreciate that um
so yeah i i do feel lighter right now
just letting it all out i do also want
to just talk about all the good stuff
luca is so freaking adorable
so is there like a certain amount of
time until we can see him because of
like baby stuff well yeah so that's the
thing i i left it in casey's hands
because i'm like you know like what
would you feel comfortable with and so i
loved it yeah so like he he said he
wanted to wait until like we searched
like when do babies get their immune
system developed and it's about the
three-month mark
so he told his family like don't come
until lucas three months
um
the only person that has seen luca other
than me casey and isaac is my mom like
she's
she's the only one that and she held him
only once
she's seen him twice but like at a
distance
but yeah it's just
that's just what casey's wishes he
wanted to be really careful but then now
like all this time has passed he's lucas
is about to get his two-month shots so
we discussed it again in case he's like
maybe after his shots and i'm like
whatever you feel comfortable yeah so
sweet that's awesome yeah i've been
sending tiff like voice messages
make sure he listens to it okay yeah
it's me your theogina you don't know who
i am
yeah i love seeing the involvement of
both parents i love seeing dads being
involved i hate the narrative that men
are not always involved in their
children's lives
babysit their kids
your son is with his father yeah exactly
exactly you live in your life what the
[ __ ] you think is supposed to happen
people comment like
your your husband isn't just like a free
babysitter it's like
that's the best
yeah so i'm the free babysitter right
and i love the fact that you are
discussing that he has an option that he
has an opinion in his child's life as
well again it's the narrative that we've
just been fed and it's not the norm it's
really not because i think of tim too as
a father you know um the way that
tim's scheduling is around beta sleep
it is it should be you know yeah but
it's like you know you there we have
this going on and having the
conversations and you see active fathers
and i was raised a lot by my dad my mom
was a working mother and my dad was very
hands-on with everything you know and
that's what i've always seen so i've
just is
hearing um a lot of other people's
stories about like well you know
unfortunately there are absentee fathers
there are you know mothers that are
going through postpartum there are some
people that don't connect with the
babies like every story is so different
but it is really nice to hear having a
male
involved with their child's life should
not be something that's surprising they
have an opinion they made the baby you
are having a conversation with your
partner with your husband and doing
what's best for your child and i think
that's what makes the hard moments when
parenting comes around or relationships
really easier to work through because
now you're both being heard and you both
have a say yeah and
i want to see your baby yeah
i just want to smell him i love that new
girl oh yeah he's still amazing
i need to stop being around people with
cute ass kids cuz i'm over here like hey
y'all be looking good after two i'm like
i think i can do it
i was like i'm in radio for a reason
yeah yeah
it's all good
oh
little toes i know oh my god i got a
question are you eating your placenta uh
i i couldn't even if i wanted to they
[ __ ] threw it away right away
wait wait wait they threw away your
placenta yeah they didn't even ask or
not i mean whatever okay i wasn't
planning for it uh-huh
but because i don't know
they talked about cooking it i don't
remember it didn't eat it yeah i don't
remember i don't know
i was considering doing the
encapsulation yeah but he came so fast i
didn't even get to that point but they
don't land they just tossed it out
yeah they didn't even ask you no
okay so we got some we've got they don't
ask like that's the thing that i learned
oh they don't ask they don't ask you for
anything they didn't ask me if i could
have students in the [ __ ]
room they didn't ask me if they could
stick their fingers up my vagina while
i'm in the middle of pushing this kid
out they didn't ask um
for freaking casey to cut the umbilical
cord damn like they didn't ask anything
like
it was whatever i don't know i think you
should be but i'm not going to say like
okay one thing i do need to say because
i know a lot of people are going to feel
strongly about this my experience does
not mean it's going to be the same
experience for everyone right my first
the hospital staff that i had doesn't
mean that all hospital staff treat their
patients that way the policies that this
stupid-ass hospital had doesn't mean
that all the hospitals happen so
that's just
saying but you have to but i have to say
it yes
but learning an experience i know when
that day comes i'll be
tiff yeah all right what is going on i
feel so passionate about this now after
learning because with isaac he was a
c-section i was 18. i didn't know
anything i was just
falling in line with the
way things are done already that's the
thing like that's now that i've educated
myself i find it really disappointing
that
pregnant moms are just like oh i don't
know i mean the doctor knows right like
let me just leave it up to his hands
like girl no this is your body your baby
you educate yourself look up
evidence-based birth just look up that
website and educate yourself like
there's so much
there's so many things that are just
done because of procedure policy
whatever and then as a patient you're
like well i trust my doctor has the best
interest in mind right and i'm not
saying that they don't it's just that
they might be
taught things that don't make sense yeah
and it's okay to have an opinion about
your body yeah it is your body i really
believe there's uh we're gonna we should
be seeing a lot more content uh from you
when it comes to this because there are
tons of women and men that are going to
learn a lot from your experience and i i
know i have a ton of questions i know
when that day comes i'm gonna
be asking you a ton of questions and not
just about like how am i supposed to
watch this but how am i supposed to make
it live
seriously
i look at my parents like
how did y'all do this because i know
i was running into everything i'm not
supposed to be here yeah babies are
hell-bent on just killing themselves
dude like that's crazy
we're gonna have a lot of questions but
you should continue to um
educate others um provide resources i
think it's very important it becomes a
support uh you have a group i see why
mothers gravitate towards each other
yeah instead of just talking about it
with everyone else but i think this is
great it starts such an amazing
conversation um with your partner i know
it makes me now think of
which i do think of who is uh who would
i like to go through that process oh
yeah that's a that's a big thing i
consider with dating
because you know your girl what's up
your girl wants a baby one day
one day not today or tomorrow but
eventually so yeah thank you for sharing
thank you girl gina we didn't get to you
that's fine you're you're way more
important and interesting
i got two tv shows whatever i'm thinking
i got two tv shows
dungeons and dragons show coming out
yeah
tv i got two shows on there attacking
the show
thank you and invitational party where i
literally play i get paid to play
dungeons and dragons on tv
[ __ ] that's so hard it's so much fun and
then dungeons and dragons the actual uh
watsy wizards of the coast that made
dungeons and dragons just hired me on a
new show that i'm doing every wednesday
now that'll be on the official dnd uh
thank you the official dnd youtube so do
i propose now or later where do we get
the paper like a dragon wizard wedding
there's gonna be like sports involved
they're gonna be like
this is just really strange there's
gonna be a lot they're gonna be like
sports wizard you know what we're
inviting the wizards yeah yeah the
basketball team it's like there's the
tattoo
combination perfect combination
exactly
that's why you're so
she's so smart
they say
that the perfect person doesn't exist
right
here she has yellow hair
um yeah so that's i mean that's the only
thing that's an update oh i released
merch like a small merchandise
it was kind of like it was kind of like
a meme merch like just trolley because i
made an abg merch i love it like for fun
you know small drop for fun um because i
started working with the new merch
company that my agency got me and we did
well and then i'll be working on new
merch soon dropping that for a more like
broader audience
uh but other than that you know same
thing you know waking up in the mornings
crying because the sun's barely up you
know i have to commute now and now the
gas prices are high [ __ ] this russian is
not a [ __ ] act
and like the one year that i start
commuting for work i gotta pay six bucks
a gallon now so you know shit's just it
hurts
uh yeah but uh other than that nothing
crazy nothing big i think the big story
here is we got a baby in the house
you know
that's what i wanted to hear so yeah but
if you guys look we got to wrap this up
i know i got a pump yeah
oh
um yeah they're rock hard now they're
full make sure you guys check out tiff's
tiffin cases youtube channel yeah i'm
sure they're gonna post way more stories
about this more in detail what happened
what's going on what's up with baby luca
check out nikki all her socials will be
here she's coming out with shoes and
stuff oh i can't wait to see them thanks
um but other than that thank you so much
for watching yeah and check out gina on
everything
hello g4 tv we're on linear we're on
television we're on cable network and
we're also on twitch and youtube check
out g4tv but also check out my stream on
twitch twitch.tv slash miss gina darling
um uh check out all of there are links
down below whatever you know like check
out our sponsors buy it make us look
good yeah and we will see you guys next
episode we love you
[Music]
you